parlez-nous un peu de vous j'ai
décidé quand je veux le raconter un concours
que peut-être je vais essayer à Hollywood
la Vierge où beaucoup a émergé certains
gars n'arrêtent jamais de chercher à cacher le
salami qu'est-ce que l'acte tremper la mèche
beurrer le muffin  Je comprends
salut je suis Frank salut deux semaines à Los Angeles
tu travailles pour Howard Hughes pas de
mal 'ayant de grands espoirs madame 400 $ par
semaine en plus pendant que j'ai lu sur
Howard Hughes j'espère qu'il inspecte  il
vous rencontrer dans une chambre d'hôtel mr.  Hughes
je voudrais te remercier pour mes
cours de théâtre merci pour mes cours de ballet
et merci pour la chance de devenir une
star qu'est-ce qu'elle fout ici tu as dit que
tu voulais grandir avec ça euh oui
Marilyn Monroe ah c'est  Marlin Mabry,
elle est une religieuse baptiste et vous savez pourquoi le
sexe est mauvais, non ouais parce que cela
pourrait conduire à la danse peut-être que je ne suis pas la
bonne fille pour ça Je suis une
actrice de cinéma carrée devrait avoir de gros seins pour être
sexy  dans cette ville ne sont-ils pas les
règles tu es une exception les règles
ne s'appliquent pas à toi un jour j'ai dit à mon
ami que j'étais terrible était-il trop
tard pour le faire ma fiancée croit qu'une fois que
tu as été intime et que le  yeux de Dieu
tu es engagé envers cette personne pour le
reste de ta vie
donc elle croit que tu es déjà
marié si quelqu'un qui travaille pour moi
veut nouer une relation avec l'une de
nos actrices sous contrat je dois virer
qu'est ce que tu fais  tu as un
permis de conduire ne vas
-tu pas t'as entendu fr  om les gens que je suis
fou
tu n'es pas comme les autres tu es une
exception quelque chose que nous n'avions pas prévu
s'est produit est-ce
que quelqu'un a donné ça à
nous l'obtiendrons aussi
tu es une jeune femme douée avec un
avenir merveilleux personne n'a  plus
jeune quand tu m'as dit que les règles ne
s'appliquent pas à moi tu sais qu'elles ne s'appliquent pas à
toi non plus